morning everybody it is seven o'clock
you are very welcome to join us on our
breakfast show here on sky news police
in denmark have confirmed that three
people
shot dead and three critically injured
when a gunman opened fire in one of
copenhagen's busiest shopping malls on
sunday evening
a 22 year old danish man has been
charged with manslaughter and will
appear in court later on today he was
pictured waving what appeared to be a
rifle above his head police have not
ruled out terrorism as a motive also
coming up we'll have the latest from
copenhagen and as boris johnson faces
further criticism of his leadership
we'll speak to the education minister
will quince it is monday the 4th of july
hundreds flee as a gunman opens fire in
a shopping mall in copenhagen witnesses
describe the attack as pure terror
pressure mounts on boris johnson are
over allegations that he failed to act
on warnings of sexual misconduct by his
now resigned deputy chief whip
i'm here in kiev where president
zielenski remains defiant after this
eastern city of lizzy shansk falls to
russian forces
i'm on the outskirts of sydney where
thousands of families have been forced
to evacuate their homes after a month's
worth of rain fell in just two days
back at home more chaotic scenes at
airports around the country with
hundreds of flights delayed or cancelled
altogether
and drama at the british grand prix
chinese driver joe ginwa gino says his
car's halo device saved his life
how dramatic was that also coming up on
the program for you this morning we'll
bring you the extraordinary story of the
british arctic explorer who was accused
of spying against russia and imprisoned
in siberia while on his travels
and the royal mail reports that 32
postmen and women are attacked by dogs
every week bad dogs or bad owners will
get the view of a dog trainer
[Music]
morning everybody three people have been
shot dead in one of copenhagen's biggest
shopping centres police say that a 22
year old danish man has been arrested
and charged over what the country's
prime minister described as a cruel
attack
at a media briefing late last night they
promised a massive presence in the
danish capital until they're certain
that the gunman was acting alone
the attack happened at the fields
shopping centre near the centre of
copenhagen our europe correspondent
yvonne robbins reports
[Applause]
[Music]
in copenhagen
people are running for their lives
shoppers desperately trying to escape
and this is why
inside a mall a man can be seen pacing
with a gun
something grabs his attention
and he runs off
armed police are on the scene
trying to get people to safety
i saw people running away from tomorrow
we thought that it was some fans that
were seeing harry styles we were
supposed to
have a concert in
half an hour so but
after some time the cops came ambulance
and the
firemen came i went outside to our
reception
and and i asked what was happening and
some said it tells us shooting
as police surround the building
inside they're tracking the gunman
people are told to hide
officers later confirmed a 22 year old
danish man had been arrested
they said terrorism couldn't be ruled
out
do you visit fully how focused what
we're looking at now is whether we're
dealing with just the suspects who we
apprehended alone or if this is
something that was done with others
pop star harry's styles cancelled a
concert he was playing nearby and in a
message online said he was praying for
all involved
this city now remains on high alert
several people have died
several others have been injured
victims in a shooting where the motive
remains unclear
siobhan robbins sky news
joining us now is will quince minister
estate for children and families just a
quick thought on that three people going
about their business shopping shot dead
totally appalling and
my heart goes out and thoughts and
prayers with the the family of everyone
involved is just truly awful yeah a man
appearing in court later on today so we
can't really say much more than that at
this stage but uh we can talk about what
on earth is going on with the sleaze in
your party um first of all tell me for
the benefit of our viewers at home this
morning morning wherever you're watching
us um what are the responsibilities of a
deputy chief whip
so the deputy chief whip is is all about
bit pastoral care but it's also about
ensuring discipline and the the
management and running of um of
parliament in an effect that in effect
the house of commons chamber so when you
see somebody
uh like mr prince you're behaving in the
way that he did i mean does that not
bring the whole process into disrepute
well it it it's totally appalling and i
was i was shocked when i saw the news on
late on thursday night and then saw the
resignation and then the whip being
withdrawn on on the friday and the new
reality is parliament is 650 mps and
what i see day in day out is
people working hard for their
constituents and to try and make this
country a better place for not just
their constituents but
everyone so children have better life
chances than their their parents and
there's no question that you know
allegations of this nature and of course
we've got to have due proc process of to
follow does huge damage to the
reputation and trust in parliament and
of course that hurts us all so what do
you do about it well it's right the due
process follows the first thing is it's
really important that people make
complaints and call out behavior that is
in this case you know what appears to be
totally
totally unacceptable if the allegation
is serious of course i would encourage
people to go to the police they should
also go to the parliamentary authorities
in particular if it happens on the
parliamentary estate because that's
exactly the way through a formal
complaint process that action can be
taken as it was in this case with the
prime minister and the chief work taking
the decision to withdraw the whip
i mean it's charming to have you uh here
today not particularly well known to my
viewers but i come back whenever you
want
i'm reading in the paper this morning
that junior ministers are being sent out
to deal with the press um and to talk to
viewers back home because senior
ministers just can't face um defending
people like the former deputy chief whit
well i'm certainly not going to defend
the former deputy chief with the
allegations are incredibly serious and
i'm appalled uh by them but that that
isn't the case uh today because i was
booked in four days ago in fact five
days ago i think it was to talk about
very important child care and we'll come
to that announcement we're going to
again to come to that um but but of
course the the actions as alleged are
indefensible i don't think you'll see
anybody come forward and say anything
other than that and given um you've
we've all heard the allegations and read
about them over the weekend do you think
they're serious enough for the police to
get involved
so i think that is a matter for the
police but i think it's important if we
only approach of course and i think the
key thing is that we create an
environment where everybody feels that
if they witness or if they are the
victim of sexual assault or predatory
behavior of this nature in line with
these allegations that they feel able to
go to the police and the authorities
because that's exactly how
investigations can follow and due
process take its course well wonder why
the prime minister gave him a job
well look it's it's a fair question and
i anticipated that and i i spoke with
number 10 both yesterday and today and i
asked them firmly and clearly for an
answer on this and i've been given
categorical assurance that the prime
minister was not aware of any serious uh
specific allegation with regards to the
former deputy chief whitman seems that
lots of people around the prime minister
were but the prime minister himself
wasn't
so all i can say is what i've i've heard
and that's that the prime minister
wasn't aware of any specific allegation
or complaint with regards to the former
deputy chief whip and i think these
cases are hard because like any
professional organization you can't act
on rumor or gossip and as you know in
westminster there is a lot of rumor or
gossip it's something i try to sort of
stay clear of but it's why it's also so
important that where people do witness
something which is clearly falling well
below the the standard behavior we
should uh rightly expect from members of
parliament and those who work on the
parliamentary estate that it's reported
and we encourage everybody to come
forward and whether that's the police or
the parliamentary authorities so action
can be taken like it was in this case
with the chief whip and the prime
minister the very next day withdrawing
the whip it took them 21 hours though
well
i don't think that's entirely fair
because i think the deputy chief whip
resigned the previous evening and then
the next day i believe a for a formal
complaint was made and it was on the
basis of that complaint being made that
the whip was then withdrawn do you think
he should resign his suit
so that's not that's not a matter for me
and no i'm interested in your view so it
it we've got to let due process follow
and follow its course so i would
encourage the first thing is everybody
and anybody who has witnessed or who has
been the victim of um behavior that they
believed to be below the standard
expected then they should report it and
then that's a matter for the police and
the parliamentary authorities the reason
i ask is because i heard from the um
former mp for tiverton and honington who
lost his who actually was forced to
resign his seat he feels it's double
standards and there's one rule for what
happened with him what he was watching
on his phone in the chamber and the
physical alleged physical assaults that
this guy's been up to i think every case
has to be taken on a case-by-case basis
clearly the the behavior there was
unacceptable also and do i think neil
parish made the right decision yes i do
ultimately it was his decision to resign
his seat in this case now the whip spin
withdrawn there will be a formal
investigation the key thing is kay that
as many people and anybody who has
witnessed or had experience as a victim
of any kind of sexual predatory behavior
comes forward and reports that it is
once again challenging the um ethical
judgment though of the prime minister is
it not i hear what you say that the
prime minister says he doesn't know
about the actual details but if we look
back at some of the other stuff that's
been going on not least lord guide who
was the ethics advisor to the prime
minister he resigned 19 days ago at the
moment he doesn't have an ethics advisor
that is the case i've no doubt the prime
minister intends to uh appoint one but
you know i think on this case if you
look at what happened in terms of an
allegation was made the very same and a
complaint made the very same day the
chief whip and the prime minister
withdrew the whip you've now got to let
due process i understand the allegations
are being disputed so you've got to let
due process follow its course but i'm
absolutely confident that the
investigation will take place and then
the appropriate action will be taken and
if any of these claims against him are
proven he should then lose his c well
that's some that's a massive parliament
and we have clear processes and
procedures in place around recall yeah
but you wouldn't be happy sitting next
stream would you in the chamber well
it's it's not a matter for me and it's
and it's absolutely wrong and i'm
interested to know what your view is
because i'm sure a lot of my viewers
this morning will think well i wouldn't
want to sit next to you
the allegations are shocking and
appalling uh and and i can understand
why colleagues would indeed feel that
way but in terms of who represents a
seat in parliament that is ultimately up
to the constituents of
of that individual member of parliament
but of course there are clear procedures
and processes around recall in place but
i think we're jumping the gun a bit
because there is due process and we've
got to make sure that investigation
follows it will all depend on the length
of the investigation and that will be no
doubt in the hands of the police and the
parliamentary authorities okay so you
think the police will get involved i
don't know okay i don't know it all
depends on who comes forward talk to me
about um your um planned child care can
i call them reforms yeah you certainly
can so this is all about improving the
accessibility the availability and
important the affordability of child
care and early years education so it's
about encouraging more child minders
into the market which we know has been a
declining sector over the past few years
it's about ratio reforms we've got a
consultation on ratio reform and fairer
funding it's about an extra 10 million
pounds pumped in to maintain nursery
schools and it's also about generally
just looking at what more we can do over
the next few years around child care and
earlier education whilst of course
maintaining that high quality uh
ensuring that safety is paramount fewer
stuff though
um
fewer in in what way in terms of ratios
yeah well what we're proposing is moving
from a one to four currently to the
scottish model which is one to five and
it'll be up to each individual setting
it's not a a target it's a very much a
legal cap it's a maximum and it is
designed to give uh individual settings
and providers that flexibility as to how
they safely provide the high quality
care within their setting why do it if
it's not going to save any money well i
didn't say it wouldn't save money in
fact if p if people follow through with
it it could save money and we've we've
modeled what that would look like but at
the moment some settings and the great
thing about our earlier setting and we
have 97 that are good or outstanding so
we have some of the highest quality
early as education uh in the world it's
about giving them that flexibility
whether it's around staff training or
covering lunch breaks so parents don't
turn up that day because of star
sickness or whatever else that that um
they aren't going to be able to have a
child have a place in that setting in
that day so it's not saying they have to
move these ratios it's giving them the
option to do so and that's why we're
consulting on it and i very much want to
hear the views of the sector well you
say that but i mean you went to paris
with aratomara on friday nfi by the way
um and you said that um it's not going
to save any money and it's not a silver
bullet so i said it's not a silver
bullet and i didn't say it's not going
to save money i said it could save money
but it's not a silver bullet in terms of
dramatically reducing the cost for
parents it's more about flexibility for
settings which will then ultimately in
the medium to long term could save money
but it's part of a wider package of
measures including for example ensuring
that parents who could and should be
eligible to to in some cases thousands
of pounds of government support through
entitlements through tax-free child care
and of course through the universal
credit offer which is 85 of childcare
costs making sure that they're accessing
the entitlements that they're currently
not receiving and in some cases it's
hundreds of thousands of people that
could and should be eligible for this
funding which could be up to you know
several thousand pounds a year so will
it save my viewers money or not so it
what it will do so ratios will in the
medium to long term save money yes but
the key thing today actually is about
hundreds of thousands of people who
aren't accessing the government support
be it the two or the three and
four-year-old offer or indeed tax-free
childcare and universal credit making
sure that they're getting the
entitlement that they should be at the
moment which can be worth up to several
thousand pounds now you have a little
bit of a conflict of interest in that
your missus is a teacher she wants 12
percent your boss wants to give a nine
percent
that's going to be tricky isn't it at
home over dinner well you you're yeah
i'm going to be in a tricky situation
with a wife as a teacher and an asenko
um so it's something we don't discuss at
home okay but
you're right i mean these are these are
difficult times and we know that there's
the global global inflationary pressures
and the government has to tread that
path very carefully we have independent
uh salary and pay review bodies and it's
important that we wait for those
recommendations and don't pre-judge them
okay i can't let you go without talking
dogs we both yes doctors look at his
face light up as soon as i said there we
go there we go we're doing a story later
on about posties being attacked by dogs
apparently um something like thousands
are attacked um every year are they bad
dogs or bad owners
well i i
it's probably a mixture of the two in
terms of it's really important as you
know okay when you get a dog that you
invest the time to train them properly i
think there are steps that everyone can
take at home so you know when we've had
a dog at home and you know we look after
our neighbors and when i've had them
with my parents you can put guards over
your letterbox which can prevent these
things from happening like cages that
catch the post and also if you alert the
post office they'll put a red sticker
against your address so they know that
there's a dog on the premises so i think
it's about being a responsible dog owner
okay i always think there's no such
thing as bad dogs just bad owners um
thank you very much indeed minister for
joining us much appreciated thank you
very much indeed uh let's bring you uh
an update from copenhagen i should be
the police chief has said this morning
there is no indication that the attack
in a shopping mall was actually an
attack of terror though i'm sure people
involved were absolutely terrified he
revealed that one of the three people
who was shot dead was a russian residing
in denmark
looking at the front pages before you
know the metro leads on number 10
struggle to defend claims the prime
minister did not know about the
conservative chris pincher's alleged
reputation for groping
pm facing cabinet backlash over pincher
the headline in the telegraph for you
this morning
the times claims the upset has
revitalized plans to oust boris johnson
austerity driven cuts have left over one
and a half million children from single
parent families in poverty thus
according to research in the guardian
the daily mail meanwhile says 22 000
crime suspects fail to turn up to court
that's in their exclusive on monday
some pictures the only ways essex star
who was involved in a car crash in
turkey which killed her boyfriend jake
mclean
and happy scorch of july says the daily
star as it predicts we could see
temperatures of up to 36 degrees
this coming week
still to come on the programme for you
this morning as russia claims victory in
the strategically important ukrainian
city of lishanks it'll be i'll be i'll
be joined usher today by a military
expert michael clark to assess whether
the war has now swung in vladimir
putin's favor
then joined by a criminal barrister as
her colleagues prepare to go on strike
for a second week
and in the next hour we'll get more
reaction to the latest scandal engulfing
the conservative party with shadow
cabinet office minister jenny chapman
the ukrainian president has issued a
defiant statement after russian forces
occupied the last remaining city
in the eastern city
or eastern state of luhansk in his
nightly address he said his forces would
reclaim all of the land lost to russia
the shanks was the last remaining
ukrainian health city in the eastern
luhansk region it's captured by russian
forces
will be seen as a landmark victory for
vladimir putin in his attempts to take
the entire donbass region
sally's standing by for us in kiev this
morning this is bad news isn't it for
the ukrainians
it certainly is kay uh it's certainly a
significant moment uh in this war and i
would say one that many expected in
recent days
and it certainly seems like it was a
tactical decision by the ukrainian
forces to withdraw uh yesterday uh
albeit under heavy um fire uh because
there was a danger that they were going
to become surrounded by russian forces
in that city of lizzie schansk thousands
of them which would have been an
absolute uh disaster now in his knightly
address president zelinski remained
defiant as you say uh but he's also
called for more weapons because the main
issue for ukrainian forces here is they
were completely outgunned by the
russians in lissy schansk now of course
that means that the whole luhansk region
is now controlled by russia which is
half of the donbass
and russia has made it clear that its
primary goal is to control the entire
industrial donbass
region so it will now turn its
eyes to the don yes region uh which
ukraine largely still controls huge
parts of it the fighting in the donbass
is far from over and in fact yesterday
we did already see some shelling of the
city of slaviance soviets and cremators
are the two biggest cities in the
donetsk region which remain under
ukrainian control but certainly was
heavily shelled yesterday uh in
slobiansk with at least six people
including a child uh killed uh so
ukrainian forces will now be preparing
new defensive lines uh both sides have
suffered heavy losses the big question
now is whether the ukrainians can defend
against this russian advance and whether
russia can maintain this momentum
okay thanks very much ali thank you
thousands of people living
in or around australia's biggest city
have been forced to evacuate from their
homes after heavy rains flooded several
suburbs let's find out more should we
nicole is standing by for us so much
rain nicole good morning
so we've had extraordinary rains here
all around sydney i'm in the north west
of the city but even maneuvering around
here has become very difficult
it's flooded fields and houses
businesses cars underwater you can see
one of the major
bridges just outside of sydney behind me
our cameraman is going to show you how
far that flood water extends at least a
mile it's broken it's banks it's
submerged the bridge
and people in this area when you speak
to them they say that they're expecting
things to get much worse before they get
better and that's because these rivers
the the flood levels are still
increasing they're expected to peak
overnight we've seen the emergency crews
out and about some 30 000 people have
been told to either evacuate from their
homes or to get their flood plans ready
so that when the crews say it's time to
get out they're ready to do it we've
also seen them out on boats already
having to get some people
some families out of their houses when
the waters have risen too quickly
the amazing thing here though is this
has been going on for months and months
this isn't a one-off flood some of these
areas have had three or four floods
just this year so they're exhausted
they're tired they say they clean up
from one flood and then suddenly another
flood
arrives remembering also at the
beginning of the year we had that
massive flood event up on the north
coast of new south wales in lismore 10
000 people in that area are still
homeless
so everyone here is frustrated that the
flooding is still continuing they say
that the state government and the
federal government needs to come up with
a plan to protect them but they're
living in low-lying flood-prone areas
and right now australia is in the middle
of a la nina weather event so that means
that the entire east coast of australia
is being constantly hammered by these
extreme
weather events now climate scientists
are saying that this could continue for
another couple of months over the winter
and into the spring so people are
bracing for even more flood events
two years of la nina so far and now
they're saying that this could extend
into a third year so a really pretty
dramatic scene that we have here not
only on the outskirts of sydney but
stretching along the coast
and as i said emergency crews and
officials are warning people to stay at
home to cancel their school holidays and
just wait for these flood waters to drop
okay thanks nicole thank you more than a
meter of rain in 24 hours and lots more
to come we're told
almost 32 000 people have been told to
leave their home or to prepare to leave
their home it's the fourth time as
nicole was saying in just 18 months that
the people in that area have
had to face
challenges with flooding
meantime back home and there have been
more chaotic scenes at airports around
the country with hundreds of flights
delayed or cancelled altogether some
passengers had to wait hours to collect
their bags which led to luggage being
abandoned on carousels airlines have
until friday to take advantage of a
government amnesty to hand back landing
slots and change their schedules without
facing penalties
at least six people have been killed
eight injured after glacier collapsed on
a popular hiking trail in the italian
alps rescuers could not immediately
determine how many people were in the
area and are now checking car
registrations in the car park to try to
clarify the numbers
a romanian tourist has been killed in a
second fatal shark attack off the coast
of egypt in recent days
a 68 year old austrian woman died on
friday after reportedly being attacked
by a mako shark while swimming in the
red sea near the resort town of hagarda
formula motor racing at silverstone this
weekend produced a couple of terrifying
moments two big crashes within hours of
each other experts said both could have
been deadly but for a life-saving bit of
kit called a halo kamali
this is the heart-stopping moment that
could have brought tragedy to
silverstone
his car flipped upside down formula one
driver joe guangyu is only saved from
horrific injury or worse by a relatively
new safety feature known as a halo
introduced in 2018 the halo is a
semi-circular crossbar made of titanium
and joined to the front of the car
encasing the driver's head it can take
the weight of a double decker bus but
it's proven controversial i think the
traditionalists said look they're open
cockpit cars
we don't like it because of the
aesthetics and the fans didn't like it
because they couldn't see as much of the
drivers but it's just proved to be an
absolute lifesaver and yet just hours
before guanyu's crash this happened the
halo doing its job that is a life saved
unequivocally
this was in formula two the halo is all
that stands between the head of driver
roy nissani and the car on top of him
and back in 2020 roman grosjean walked
away unhurt from this shielded by yes
his halo
so while some racing purists may not
like it it's clear that the halo is
doing what it was designed to do
save lives
kamali melbourne sky news
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
warmer and drier but the north can still
expect rain at times mainly dry and
fairly mild right now though but there
are showers around mostly as i said in
the north and the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
a quick look at what's happening in
wimbledon cameron nori is the sole
british player left in the singles at
sw19 heading into the second week of the
tournament
he is good lad he reached the last eight
of a grand slam tournament for the first
time after a straight sets win over the
american tommy paul now the watson's
best ever run at wimbledon came to an
end after she lost to germany's
julie or jewel nehemiah i should say
and looking at some of the other papers
for you this morning we have this
picture in the telegraph of a new
species of water lily that's been
discovered at kew gardens and it's the
largest ever to be recorded
could have existed a million years ago
this particular species was only
uncovered after it was grown from a
packet of seeds donated by some bolivian
researchers i'll call this out
the guardian it was the return of the
infamous soapbox racist this weekend
racers are tasked with creating their
non-motorized vehicles that are both
able to make it through the course
whilst also being as wacky
as possible
winner judged on performance as well as
inventiveness and appearance and whether
or not they actually finish
the race surprisingly not got moving
pictures of that we'll try and find you
some and finally in the express it looks
like someone didn't get the morning
coffee captured on india's rampham board
national park the picture shows a female
tiger there she is krishna
lashing out at a mate
there you go not sure whether she caused
any problems or not
um that's the expressway uh still to
come on the program we'll have more
reaction as the strategically
significant ukrainian city falls to the
russians that come
[Music]
morning again everybody thanks for
having me breakfast with us here on sky
news this morning tomorrow here in just
a second but first let's tell you what's
been happening in denmark overnight
three people have been killed in a
shooting at a shopping mall in the
capital a 22 year old danish man has
been arrested and charged with the
attack police said this morning he acted
alone and shot his victims at random
zielenski has said ukraine will reclaim
all of its land lost in the war as the
eastern city of lishchang falls to
russian forces
labour demanding boris johnson sets out
exactly what he knew about allegations
of inappropriate behaviour by the mp
chris pincher before he was appointed to
the tory whips office the education
minister told this program downing
street had received no specific
complaint
[Music]
well let's tell you a little bit more
about what the minister's been telling
us this morning he told us that the
allegations of groping leveled against
the former deputy chief whip damaged the
reputation and trust of parliament well
quince also told me he was sure the
prime minister had no knowledge of
previous allegations made against chris
pincher before he appointed him to the
role
there's no question that allegations of
this nature and of course we've got to
have due proc process of to follow does
huge damage to the reputation and trust
in parliament and of course that hurts
us all i asked them firmly and clearly
for an answer on this and i've been
given categorical assurance that the
prime minister was not aware of any
serious uh specific allegation with
regards to the former deputy chief whit
seems that lots of people around the
prime minister were but the prime
minister himself wasn't
so all i can say is what i've i've heard
and that's that the prime minister
wasn't aware of any specific allegation
or complaint with regards to the former
deputy chief whip
tamara's here and he was saying the
allegations are appalling he's saying
they're appalling that he's not going to
defend the deputy chief whip and that no
one else is either now there have been a
slew of allegations uh surfacing in the
weekend papers about chris pincher
dating from the last decade but many of
them occurred allegedly quite recently
2019 2020 2021 and
you're seeing now conservative mps
unwilling to defend him although he
through his lawyers has denied any
inappropriate behavior in many of those
cases the question is did the prime
minister know anything about it will
quince the minister we just had on said
that he's received a categorical
assurance that the prime minister didn't
and that he the prime minister can't act
on the basis of rumors downing street
today tell me that this appointment was
referred to the propriety and ethics
team at the cabinet office they looked
into it they didn't raise any objections
and that is what the prime minister acts
on but when you've got allegations in
the newspapers particularly in the
sunday times that the prime minister was
warned personally was told personally
that people had been victims of
inappropriate behavior by mr pincher if
anything surfaces to suggest that
downing street's version of events is
not correct when they say the prime
minister didn't know of any specific
allegations then this could get get more
damaging for boris johnson who is uh
facing a grilling by mps on wednesday at
the liaison committee i think one of his
least favorite amendments and the
liaison committee is all of these all
the chairs of the other committees many
of whom are his vocal critics okay and
we'll see you at nine o'clock for
tomorrow's take look forward to it thank
you
uh meanwhile let's return to the war in
ukraine and get more reaction to the
fall of the eastern ukrainian city of le
shanks to russian forces joining us now
is the former director of the royal
united services institution rusi and
that's professor michael clark hello
professor thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning however you look
at it this is bad news for ukraine
uh well it's fairly inevitable news and
when severo donetsk fell which is the
city on the other side of the river the
shinsuke was going to be the next point
to defend
the ukrainians had actually quite strong
defensive positions in the chance on the
high ground overlooking the river but
the russians actually for once were able
to maneuver in ways they haven't been
able to from the beginning of this war
um and get behind them and so last week
there was a news blackout in kiev for
for a few days and we all thought that's
probably because they were withdrawing
and they were so they haven't in a sense
been beaten in leicestershire but
they've withdrawn from it because they
couldn't allow themselves to be
surrounded so yes it's a loss but the uh
ukrainians certainly are not losing too
many troops now because they've
withdrawn in good order it's been a
fighting withdrawal and now they seem to
be out and they'll be moving back
westwards i suspect towards uh slavian's
kramatorsk which is the next strong
point that they will want to defend
um
is it now also though inevitable that at
least for now they will lose the whole
of the donbass region
no
they've certainly lost luhansk which is
the smaller of the two oblasts the two
regions that make up the whole donbass
um so that's gone for that for now
uh the the bigger one is donetsk
and the russians or russian forces
occupy about half of donetsk they occupy
the eastern half but not the western
half and they won't get the whole of
donetsk until they take slavian kramatos
which will be quite a
struggle for them so yes this is this is
a victory for russia this is the most
significant advance and victory they've
had since uh march the uh 25th i think
it was when they announced that they
were uh making the donbass their main
line of of uh offensive but they have
said they want the hold of the donbass
and they don't get that until they take
slavian particularly kramatorsk
uh what about snake island now we
remember snake island from the very
beginning of this war don't we uh when
one of the young sailors stood up to the
the russians who were telling him and
others to surrender um
why have the russians given back snake
island or it certainly appears that
that's what they've done
yeah well they've just abandoned it
because the position there was untenable
they were establishing um air defense
assets on snake island to give them
control of the air space above it and
also by implication also the the sea
lanes in and out of odessa but it was
just just within artillery range of um
these new guns that the ukrainians have
got almost certainly the french caesar
guns the 155 millimeter ones with a
special shell which gives it a little
bit of extra range it was just within
artillery range and although the
russians had air defense and missile
defense
there's no defense against artillery
shells they're too small and they travel
too quickly and so the ukrainians just
bombarded them with artillery on snake
island to the point where the russians
simply couldn't stay and they they left
last week they left one of their air
defense missile batteries um and one of
their radars intact which they shouldn't
have done the following day they tried
to bomb it to bomb their own facility so
the ukrainians couldn't use it and they
they dropped four bombs and missed with
three of them hit with one of them um
three fell in the sea one of them fell
on the island it's not clear whether
that facility is still um operational
whether they did hit what they were
aiming at on the island um the
ukrainians probably won't occupy the
island in any force because anyone on
snake island is vulnerable to some sort
of attack but certainly the russians now
don't have it so it makes odessa that
little bit safer
how
is ukraine and the
the west gonna get this grain out of the
country the silos are full uh they're
about to start bringing in the grain
again and there's nowhere to put it
yeah i mean there's between 20 and 25
million tons of grain stacked up in a
death so they can't get out um in a
couple of months by the end of august
there'll be another 70 000 tons which
will either be destroyed or will be
backed up against that
and there's 300 to 400 million people in
the world waiting for it who are in food
poverty of one sort another some of them
on the verge of starvation
the only way the only way that
significant amounts of grain will get
out of odessa
is if the grain carriers the ships are
allowed out in some sort of protected
convoy now that would depend on the
agreement of uh russia
which won't come without major
concessions on sanctions and the
agreement of turkey
the other variation on that idea
because you can't move enough grain over
land it has to move by sea to move in
the tonnages that is required so the
only variation is some sort of
international uh body may be sanctioned
at the u.n possibly um
simply to go in and take the grain out
and
protect convoys going in and out
and dare the russians to attack it just
dare them to try to stop it happening in
the in the face of a humanitarian need
that's another possibility it's the only
way it might work but very very
dangerous um and it would require some
demining not too difficult actually of
the of the mines around a death so
that's that's a straightforward job but
somebody would have to do it the british
and the french you've got good demining
assets uh
nato countries could demine
uh lanes out of odessa
ships could come through those lanes be
protected all the way down through the
bosphorus into the mediterranean
and dare the russian black sea fleet to
interfere
yeah but that's a big risk is it isn't
it for ukraine why would they clear the
mines away when they would just
potentially be clearing a channel for
the russian ships to come in
well they can close it again i mean if
you clear a minefield i mean in the
second world war britain had
malta very very heavily mined and we had
we had lanes through the minefields we
got our ships in and out all the time so
um
you don't have to clear a whole
minefield in order to get ships out you
simply have to clear a lane and then you
can close the lane again afterwards
that's not a particular problem but you
need the assets to do it you need modern
mining ships so counter mining ships and
mine layers in order to do it so it can
be done
but the ukrainians probably can't do it
on their own they would have to do it
with nato assets and the whole thing
would increase the danger of a
confrontation of course between nato
forces and russian forces
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us as always much appreciated
more chaotic scenes at airports around
the country with hundreds of flights
delayed or cancelled altogether some
passengers had to wait hours to collect
their bags which led to luggage being
abandoned on carousels let's find out
more should we maddie standing by at
heathrow for us maddie i was speaking um
to a colleague this morning who was
telling
telling me that she knew it was going to
be a challenge in the baggage reclaim
hall when they got there and people were
lying on the floor
good morning k yes it has been a chaotic
summer for travellers there have been
delays cues and cancellations at nearly
every airport and airline
and just last week at heathrow first of
all there was
there was a shortage of security staff
that meant that flights were cancelled
and then they were the airport's fueling
systems had a problem which meant there
were even more delays and those those
bags just piled up but one thing the
government has done to try and ease this
situation is it's relaxed the rules on
airport slots at airports um airline
slots at airports even meaning that uh
for up until this friday airlines can
change their schedules and cancel
flights without penalty without losing
those very valuable slots next year
which will allow them to fly far more
manageable schedules at least until
their um staffing levels have recovered
and built back up the idea is to avoid
more of those last minute cancellations
that have caused so much chaos as
travellers have turned up at the airport
only to discover their flight isn't
flying um now that's been welcomed by
heathrow they say it will bring much
needed clarity and um
uh for consumers give them more
confidence when they're traveling but it
does mean that this week until that
deadline we might see more cancellations
announced
good to see you thanks very much
we'll be speaking to a travel expert
if you're planning to go on holiday over
the next few weeks especially with the
kids as school breaks up any top tips on
how to make sure that you don't get
caught up in all of that aggro at the
airports at meantime with reports of
continued industrial action across a
number of sectors in the uk there are
warnings that britain could be heading
towards a summer of discontent
barristers are set to continue their
strike into a second week with
gatherings of lawyers expected at courts
around the country joining us now is
kirstie brimelow who is a criminal
barrister hi kirsty thanks for joining
us on the program this morning and the
government say they're offering you 15
you're not having any more
yes the government actually isn't
offering 15 what it's offering is 15
which will reach barristers in around a
year or two years time
because the increase would relate to new
cases only obviously currently we have a
backlog of about 58 000 cases and so the
concern
of the criminal bar and there is one of
the reasons why the criminal barristers
are taking this action
is because there just simply are
unlikely to be sufficient barristers
left in two years time
uh we've seen uh a quarter
of junior barristers
stop stopped practicing in criminal law
over the past five years
and obviously legal aid as has been
widely reported
has been slashed
by
40 percent
since
2016.
and so the 15
doesn't go anywhere near to reverse some
of those cuts it also doesn't address
the 23
collapse in barrister's earnings during
the pandemic i would add that the money
is there the government saved 240
million pounds on legal aid during the
pandemic and it's also profited
since 2010
by selling off the courts
and reducing judges sitting days it's
it's profited in over 200 million pounds
since then and that actually is one of
the reasons why we've hit such a crisis
that we are now in there was an
independent review
uh which was published um back
in 2021
where the independent review which had
been governed by the which had been
commissioned by the government
set out that the the system is in crisis
and that there needed to be an immediate
increase of a minimum of 15 annually and
obviously we'll be trotting on uh to
around a year's time since that report
and the proposal by the government will
come into play in another two years okay
but you've stopped taking legal aid
cases now haven't you as an industry
yes so the uh ballot
which uh concluded on the 20th of june
uh has decided that members will not
take
further legal aid cases nor cover
cases of their colleagues and also be
taking days of action during this month
um but that how does that help the
backlog
it doesn't help the backlog
unfortunately it's a short-term
attempt at pressurizing uh to have a
long-term effect
the system's in crisis and we have
been trying to communicate really since
the autumn since the publication of the
independent review which
supported what criminal barristers
already know but it's fallen on deaf
ears and so barristers have been driven
uh to
take this measure
um and how long are you going to go on
strike for
well currently um with we're we are
taking action this week for three days
so today tomorrow and wednesday and then
it will be four days next week five days
the week after and then alternate weeks
thereafter
good to talk to you thanks for taking
the um time to join us on the programme
this morning thank you
thank you
police in ohio have released body cam
footage showing the moment a man was
shot dead after he fled from officers
police fired around 90 rounds at him
here's joe pike
more than 60 gunshot wounds were found
on jalen walker's body
after officers fired a barrage of around
90 rounds
when they make that most critical
decision
to point their firearm at another human
being and pull the trigger
they've got to be ready to explain why
they did what they did
they need to be able to articulate
what specific threats they were facing
and that goes for every round that goes
down the barrel of their gun
and they need to be held to account
the 25 year old was unarmed when he was
shot
a firearm was found at his vehicle
earlier during a car chase police
believe mr walker fired from the
driver's seat
a casing was found close by
he later fled his vehicle wearing a ski
mask police tried to stop him with
tasers then moved on to firearms
[Music]
in the city of akron protests but from
jalen walker's family a call for calm
there are no words to describe what we
just saw
but we are begging you
that family is begging you jalen is
begging you
to stay peaceful
we will get nowhere with violence and
destruction
but we will
with measured
and calm dialogue
eight officers are now on paid leave as
an investigation attempts to understand
why another unarmed black man has been
shot and killed by police joe pike sky
news
at home now in yesterday's british grand
prix at silverstone will no doubt be
remembered as one of the races of the
formula one season and will serve as a
timely reminder of how advancements in
the sports technology can save lives
alfa romeo driver joe guan yu did not
suffer serious injuries despite being
involved in that first
lap crash that saw his car flip multiple
times before skidding upside down across
the gravel on the halo device which has
been the subject of much discussion
since it was introduced in 2018 last
year lewis hamilton credited the halo
for saving him after he was involved in
a crash at the italian grand prix with
rival max verstappen on many other
occasions as well uh joined now by tony
giandine who is member of the british
racing drivers club hi it's good to see
you and let's not forget the catch fence
as well which really saved um a lot of
those spectators
yes it did indeed and that was wasn't
mentioned too much that debris fencing
there um
having having watched some of the
footage from some of the spectators on
their iphones it was it was frightening
uh
you know there will be investigations as
to as to why when the car went through
the gravel trap it actually flipped over
the tire wall um that flipped it up into
the air and into the debris fence which
was the final amount of the cash but
also on here kate you'll notice we're
going upside down the roll hoop behind
this driver's head has actually sheared
off putting even more pressure on the
halo
to
you know ensure that he survived
then the car is actually trapped between
the tyre wall and the debris fencing
which took him
it's the reason it took them a long time
to get him out of that
car
but it it's done its job and the fia
over the last 10 years we've improved
safety so much i mean even earlier in
the day and you can see
this is george russell here who is lewis
hamilton's teammate he rushed over to
try and help the other driver as well um
but fia as i said made so many
improvements over the last 10 years the
hands device which holds the helmet into
place so your head doesn't go too far
forward to prevent you breaking your
neck
it essentially around the driver it's
like a safety cocoon and you think
there's about 40 g going into the energy
and there's the
you know the shot from the spectators
there they're ducking out of the way and
the debris didn't come through on them
also to point out roman grosjean last
year in bahrain had the most horrendous
accident when the car went through the
armco barrier
now it's absolutely certain if the halo
device had not been on that car he would
have been killed because the car also
caught fire and um he was very lucky to
emerge through the flames with just um
burnt hands so
the safety in formula one the
advancements that they've made and
especially when you see it on a high
speed circuit like silverstone very
exciting of course but very high speed
track um the halo is you know well all
priced for halo
yes sort of a ring of titanium isn't it
and just to give our viewers an idea
apparently it could take the weight of a
double decker bus on top of it and it
certainly needed that um yesterday what
did you think about george running over
to make sure the other guy was okay um
and then not being allowed to take part
in the race
it was most unfortunate for george
because his first instinct was to go and
help his fellow driver drivers towards
rushing over
the rules say that if you receive
assistance to your car
uh before a restart then you're not
allowed to restart and he had received
assistance he wasn't thinking about that
he was thinking about joe in the car and
trying to help him get out and we know
from junior races that he's done that in
karting for example um
with other drivers have gone off he's
got out of his cart to go and help them
um it's a shame because it turns out
that george's car um only had a left
rear puncture it looked like the
suspension was damaged to me but that's
a huge huge impact you know
in previous times if you go back to 2012
when uh fernando alonso who was in this
race um
had a big crash at spa at the opening
lap and one of the cars went in fact it
was roman grosjon went over his head and
scraped the top of his crash helmet i
mean he escaped death by millimeters
that was another reason together with
the death of jules bianchi in 2014 in
japan with head injuries
why they developed this safety system
the halo
and i know that you were saying was
slightly controversial at the beginning
um because when it was introduced a lot
of the
aficionados thought it it's ugly uh the
fans didn't like it because they
couldn't see the drivers they couldn't
see their helmet properly and
formula one is traditionally it's about
open wheel open cockpit cars so when
they became more enclosed the fans
didn't like it
but since that time of introduction in
2018 it has proved its worth over and
over again as an absolute lifesaver yeah
some suggestions that it should have the
livery of the helmet um on it for the
driver i'm sure it shows you
wouldn't care a jot about that given
what it did and just very quickly i mean
it saved his life didn't it he walked
away from that accident just by having
to pop into the medical center and he
was fine
he was absolutely fine he he was better
off than alex albom who was pushed into
the wall in that same crash um by
sebastian vettel and he ended up in
hospital for for a short while but again
yeah joe when you was in the paddock uh
about three hours later after the race
and formula one officials were talking
to him saw him with team bosses and then
he went on social media saying look i'm
fine thanks for the concern and just uh
quite remarkable
it was tony um it was a great race um
but thank goodness everybody was uh safe
didn't have time to talk to you about
those um trespassing on the track but
maybe we'll talk about that next time
good to see you thanks so much indeed
for joining us all today's top stories
coming up for you in just a second
[Music]